lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
resolver varios ejemplos de la sección
de ejercicios de khan academy suma y
resta de números negativos expresiones
equivalentes y esto es para asegurarnos
de que comprendemos cabalmente cómo
calcular con números positivos y
negativos así como las propiedades
aritméticas que podemos aplicar cuando
trabajamos con estos vamos a comenzar
ahora nos preguntan cuáles de las
siguientes expresiones son equivalentes
a 4 menos menos 50 elige todas las
opciones correctas veamos aquí tengo el
4 y menos menos 5 recordamos que el
negativo de un negativo va a ser un
positivo
así que esto es igual a 4 + 5 +0 bueno
al +0 pues lo podemos quitar o dejar no
estamos agregando nada es un ser nos
queda 4 + 5
aquí tenemos 4 menos menos 5 es correcta
porque no estamos poniendo el 0 pero
como no estamos sumando nada se mantiene
igual esta es una opción correcta y
ahora 45 también está aplica porque el
negativo de un negativo va a ser
positivo así que elijo estas dos
obviamente no voy a elegir ninguna de
las anteriores porque ya encontré
opciones correctas comprobamos la
respuesta
es correcta hagamos otro problema más
raúl trato de evaluar una expresión paso
a paso
3 - menos 57 encuentra el error de raúl
en el paso 1 en el paso 2 en el paso 3
raúl no cometió un error veamos 3 -
menos 5 nuevamente el negativo de un
negativo es positivo así que éste es 3 5
menos 7 y el primer paso vemos que tiene
el 3 tiene el más 5 porque el negativo
de un negativo es positivo es un +5
efectivamente esto y aquí bajo en menos
siete ahora tiene dos opciones puedes
sumar este 3 más 5 y después restarle el
7 o tener 5 menos siete la diferencia de
-2 y a eso sumarlo a 3
pero qué es lo que hizo aquí cinco menos
siete no es dos positivo
la diferencia entre 5 y menos 7 es menos
2 no más 2
aquí es donde está el error por lo que
elegimos el paso 2 comprobamos respuesta
es correcta hagamos otro problema que ya
trató de evaluar una expresión paso a
paso 3 más menos 4 menos 7 aquí están
los pasos que siguió y también tenemos
que encontrar si es que se equivocó en
alguno de estos pasos o a lo mejor que
ella no se equivocó
veamos 3 más menos 4 el positivo de un
negativo sigue siendo un negativo y
tenemos este menos 7 bueno en el primer
paso que hizo solamente le puso
paréntesis a este menos 7 y le agregó
más está sumando un número negativo que
es perfectamente válido así como este
tenemos tres más entre paréntesis menos
entonces tiene tres más uno menos cuatro
más uno menos siete este paso está bien
y lo que hace aquí es sumar este menos
cuatro con este menos siete sumamos dos
números negativos el resultado va a ser
negativo 4 7 es 11 por lo que aquí
tenemos un -11 es correcto aquí el 3 no
sufrió cambios ahora este menos 11 le
vamos a sumar un 3
la diferencia entre 11 y 3 es
efectivamente 8 y como es negativo va a
ser menos 8 así que que ya no se ha
equivocado no cometió ningún error
comprobamos respuesta es correcta nos
preguntan cuáles de las siguientes
expresiones son equivalentes a menos 19
más 3 - 6 elige todas las opciones
correctas vamos a analizar tenemos menos
19 más 3
entre paréntesis y después tenemos menos
6 muy bien esta opción tiene el menos 19
aquí es correcto tiene un más y el 3
menos 6 entre paréntesis esto es
correcto por la propiedad asociativa de
la suma y de la resta siempre y cuando
trabajemos aquí con sumas y restas
podemos asociar las de esta manera o
cambiar el orden de la asociación
tenemos los paréntesis aquí y si
cambiamos los paréntesis de esta manera
no tenemos ningún problema sigue siendo
la misma operación así que esa es una
opción correcta ahora aquí tenemos menos
16 menos 6 si a menos 19 le sumamos 3 va
a ser menos 16 en efecto menos 16 y aquí
el menos 6 se conserva esta también es
una expresión equivalente comprobamos
respuestas
es correcta vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
fred trato de evaluar una expresión paso
a paso esta es la expresión veamos aquí
lo que hizo fred en el paso a uno fue
realizar esta operación que está entre
paréntesis menos 10 más 6 la diferencia
es de 4 y como 10 el número más grande
tiene este signo negativo el resultado
también va a ser negativo así que es
menos 4 y este menos 5 se conserva este
primer paso está bien después lo que
hizo fue con la propiedad asociativa
separar este menos 5 e indicar lo como
suma menos 4 más menos 5
estamos sumando aquí dos cantidades
negativas
la suma también debería ser negativa y
sería de menos 9 pero aquí se le olvidó
poner el signo negativo es un 9 positivo
y este es un error así que el error de
fred se encuentra en el paso 3 en el
último paso vamos a comprobar la
respuesta
es correcta